body count doesn't matter why do women
lie about it
I mean a girl like it got to the point
where Shout Out J Cole
he put out in his song Whatever number
she tells you multiply by three
because men have been lied to about a
woman's body count forever you know it
is it's a conversation that always
happens and we're not trying to uncover
the body count of a woman I don't really
think anybody's really asking what's
your body count too much nowadays
however if the topic is or conversation
is brought upon
men are inclined to believe that women
are going to lie about it before they're
honest
why well it does matter and that's
that's what I gotta
like they they want it's like because
the more men you sleep with the less
valuable you are so they're trying to
sell a used Honda Civic at BMW prices
and if they tell the if they tell the
dealer the the buyer the mileage then
they have to lower the price
I agree Lonnie what about you do you
agree I don't agree
why does my body count like if you don't
know and my value is all the way up here
like what does it matter like I don't
think it's even a question to ask
someone like who cares what my body
count is okay so I agree with you on one
thing I I don't think it's like there's
a high Roi on men asking because like
what are the odds you get the truth one
and two it's like even if she is telling
the truth you're gonna assume she's
lying so like okay I mean you can ask
but I think it's the sigma but but two
um it's because but men and women are
different so they're valued for
different things like you're looking at
from a female lens so like as a woman
with a guy like we don't really care
what his body count is but men they
value Purity and youth like throughout
all of time men have always wanted pure
young virgins and so if you're not young
and you're not pure then that you're
just not what men value anymore
according to who accordingly okay
according to and that's the problem I
think there's a stigma as to what it is
that you're supposed to be and if you
have I I'm not sure even what the body
count is supposed to be it's like you're
a [ __ ] or whatever but
um we need to destigmatize that because
I think that the reason why there is an
issue because everyone's trying to
conform to society's Like rules who
cares what you're like like in my
culture if you are a virgin and you have
sex with one person that person's
supposed to marry you it's like why
there's a lot of cultures like that yeah
but I don't understand what's the point
it's like they have the least like you
know that anybody who has marriage with
zero to one
other partners right so either no other
partners or one other partners have the
highest chance of a healthy committed
marriage healthy yes
according to what well this is a new
census over the recent years
um and then they ask them do you believe
women
believe all women come on they ask what
women I can ask women so that what they
do is they survey the women when they
first get married so they first get
married they say how many partners have
you had it could be a lie right but
let's just assume everyone Lies by 20 10
like like 30. if whatever they're lying
by whatever they're lying by like
everyone has asked the same question so
they say zero Partners right then in 10
years they come back and say how happy
are you in your marriage and then they
say this is how happy and they rate them
and so then if they have zero to one
Partners like he was saying like they
have an 80 chance of a happy marriage it
seems like the cutoff point is above
five to like seven that's kind of when
you're like damaged goods well they said
actually the the the consensus that is
it's a newer consensus right and it's
um
three to nine
was well ten or more I forgot the exact
number but 10 more is like the most
likely to have a non-committed
relationship non-committed or happy
marriage right then three to nine is
then less and then obviously two was
kind of like a no man's land and then
zero to one is is actually the highest
and and it's a Higher by like that like
bottom round and how many grandmas did
they ask because I I would think that
that's the thing because if you ask my
grandma why she stayed in a marriage in
a terrible marriage for all these years
and was she still happy she'll say yeah
but that you don't think that's
beautiful no not when my grandfather was
sleeping with 25 other women at the same
time and has 25 other kids spread out
through the neighborhood
but you realize like most men so like
the idea that this is like this is a
widespread thing going on the men are
just cheating it's like it's not based
in reality though it might be your
personal experience but most men
historically didn't even reproduce so if
you want a faithful guy it's pretty easy
to find one one in three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year even historically only 40 of them
reproduce so if you don't want to go
that cheats pick one
find your friend zone
but if you choose to get a guy that
cheats then like you don't get guys that
cheat what I remember yeah so that but
I'm saying that was your grandma's
Choice okay but it's like you are saying
like you're not saying where the study
was done who it was done like you know
what I'm saying it's like it's I just
think to each his own I think that's
what I'm saying if you you want to be a
person that has one partner
Center for Disease Control in the U.S
that's where the study was done okay
okay so like and the thing is is then
you know I think that what ends up
happening is when we when people come
with
um
with stats and or studies from places
right that debunk a stereotype okay like
we have to realize that if I say hey all
men cheat right or all men are dogs it's
like well where did that study come from
and when was that done when was that
conducted you know it usually is
something that has been a stigma that's
been passed down from Generations it's
not something that's really current like
for example this is a little bit off
topic but I just found out that only
eight percent of black men
um are actually considered deadbeat dads
but if you ask the world it's a way well
in America if you ask the if you ask
America it's way bigger than that like
that's like a big thing like men don't
take care of their kids here but it's
like only eight percent of us don't
right so now it's like well we're
getting the truth now and and at this at
some point we have to understand that
the truth is what it is it's not what we
want it to be so if the truth is in my
opinion right men most men don't want a
girl and I said this I believe I said
this here before I'll say it again
men don't want a girl who has slept with
many partners and it's not because she's
a right it's because well if she is a
health is different but if you have like
10 partners for example some make your
stomach and some men can't right a man
like me I can stomach it because my
number is extremely higher than 10. some
men that no that numbers are 15. he's
looking at her like and like you know
like him and then in the same breath
what ends up happening is it's like well
what am I supposed to do with you right
am I supposed to provide for you am I
supposed to take care of you and protect
you the same so why would I do that for
somebody who has been accessible and
dispersed amongst many men you know and
at this point when we had a girl
I remember her name she said she had
over 2 000 bodies
or something like that right
okay let's see how like she had a crazy
amount of bodies she went viral
right I don't know I'll find it
um and she was like well like you know
like the stance that meant men and women
can do the same things like no we can't
unless you're gonna play by the same
exact rules across the board
like makes more money
do I blame women do you think that's a
bad do you think that's societal
pressure and like stigma
um no I think that's a woman's choice I
don't necessarily need a man to provide
or do anything for me
um I provide for myself right for my
family so you know when it comes to like
the questions like that like I don't I
don't think a man is supposed to provide
for a woman okay that is your choice if
you want a man to do that that is your
choice what about protect
so like if you were walking down the
street and someone attacked you would
you would you you feel like it's equal
rights equal Ops he shouldn't step in to
protect you I'm saying if he runs I'm
leaving him but myself
okay so it just depends on what you're
looking for I'm not looking for a man to
give me the only the only reason I say
that is like we have biological reasons
for the reasons we feel the way we feel
so there's a biological reason you would
leave him if he ran because historically
we would want someone to protect and
provide because we wouldn't pass on like
make it to the next Generation if we
didn't find someone to protect us and
provide even being a single woman like
that's a privilege because historically
we couldn't even be single we would die
someone would like kill us
or they would yeah I don't know who the
point is there's biological reasons that
you would leave him and there's
biological reasons that men feel the way
they do about body count because
historically they had to ensure
paternity and we could like shame them
for it and say you shouldn't care but
like they can't undo that feeling they
get when they think of another dude
that's like nailed his girl as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible